nobody should ever have to find out what
a human body smells like especially as
it's being eaten Sally clasped both
hands over her face trying desperately
to block out the smell and to trap in
her nervous breathing she couldn't bring
herself to look every bone in her body
wanted to take off running through the
forest back out onto the Interstate to
try and find some help but there was
nothing she could do she could never
outrun that thing it was too fast too
Savage even if she could convince
someone on the highway to pull over and
help her they would just tell her she
was going crazy maybe she was then the
smell of her husband's body drifted over
to her on the Wind as the crunching
sound of inhuman Jaws filled the air
Panic setting then silence she couldn't
hear anything not even a whisper in the
trees had she done it had she survived
that's when a red sneaker stepped out
from behind the tree and Sally stared
into the eyes of the blood spattered
Hedgehog now Sally had never been a
gamer growing up sure she played a
little bit of Mario Kart and had a few
nintend dogs back in the day but the
word gamer just wasn't for her however
love conquers all and when she found the
man of her dream she decided that it
would be worth at least giving some of
his Hobbies ago they started off nice
and easy playing a bit of stardew Valley
Minecraft and maybe some overcooked here
and there but before long the pair of
them were sitting down every day after
work headsets on and controllers in hand
ready to dive into the latest Adventure
just recently the couple had gotten into
Retro games going back and playing
Classics like Battletoads and Streets of
Rage the challenge was addictive so when
her husband John came home with a copy
of an unmarked NES game Sally was
intrigued to say the least Jon explained
that he had found it listed on eBay
under a very suspicious account he had
gone to pick up the game after work that
day expecting to be greeted by the
smiling face of the seller instead he
found the blank gray cartridge and a
very brief manual wrapped together with
an elastic band on a street corner the
seller had listed it for virtually
nothing and based on the description
seemed very eager to get rid of the game
for some reason so eager that he must
not have wanted to stick around to even
hand it over Sally already bored with
this backstory snatched the manual up
and read the title of the game Professor
Gould's terrifying horror challenge
there was no artwork no branding no
publisher no stickers nothing to
differentiate this game from being just
a blank cartridge as far as Sally knew
it could have been a virus some kind of
malware game designed to Brick their NES
but the words horror and Challenge from
the title sold her she blew on the pins
in the cartridge and slotted it into
place in the NES a black screen appeared
with nothing on it but two options
single player or two player Sally
uncoiled a second controller and handed
it to John with a grin you ready Sally
hit two player and a new screen came up
are the people holding the controllers
the people who want to play the game yes
or no Sally hit yes a shrilled beat
filled the room high pitched and grating
on their ears Jon immediately grabbed
for the remote and turned the volume
down on the TV but the beep just kept
going the screen was a bright red
filling the room with an unnatural
bloody light Jon tried to hit the off
button on the remote but the TV stayed
red and the beeping sound continued
filling their tiny apartment getting up
and rushing over to the TV John tried to
unplug it but it was no use
the beeping noise and the red screen
persisted he looked back at his wife in
confusion but she was looking somewhere
else entirely there was a rat in the
corner of the room with muddled fur
bloated flesh and cracked teeth it
stared right into Sally's eyes
salivating without a moment's hesitation
she leaped up onto the couch and
screamed but instead of running away the
rats slowly crept forward looking almost
as if it was smiling then the second one
appeared crawling out from behind the
couch followed by a third in the doorway
and a fourth beneath the TV dozens of
rats filled the room swarming in from
all directions climbing over one another
in a desperate attempt to get into the
tiny apartment to get to Sally and John
Sally clambered onto the couch with her
laptop and tried to kick away any of the
rats clambering up onto the furniture
but it was no use for every rat she
kicked away another one appeared until
soon they were climbing their way up
John's jeans their sharp little claws
digging into his flesh the rats tore at
Sally's clothes climbing over one
another desperately heading towards her
mouth trying to burrow their way in
hairy bodies filled her vision and the
stench of disease made her gag seizing
an opportunity a rat tried to clamber
through her open Jaws she felt its Tiny
Paws scrabbling at her tongue with tears
filling her eyes she took one fleeting
look at the man she loved and noticed
something behind him a giant Yellow
bottle with the words rat poison stamped
into the side was sitting precariously
on top of their cabinet half stumbling
half-swimming Sally pushed her way
through the throng of rats filling their
apartment and desperately grabbed the
bottle from on top of the cabinet
throwing the rats off her hands she
managed to unscrew the lid held the
bottle High over her head and poured the
thick stinking liquid all over the swarm
of rats threatening to engulf her the
chorus of death filled the room whether
it was the sound of the rats dying or
their bodies being evaporated by the
poison she couldn't tell all she could
do was push through to try and find her
husband and save him too and
miraculously within just a few seconds
all of the rats had disappeared the room
was empty the same as it had always been
even the big yellow bottle was gone from
her hand all she could do was stare at
Jon as he stared back at her as the
words level 1 complete appeared above
their heads welcome to
scp-1315 the most visceral most real and
most dangerous horror game you will ever
have The Misfortune of playing it's not
too late to back out at the menu screen
when you select how many players you
want it's not even too late at the
confirmation screen but once you're in
the game there's no turning back either
you beat the game or you die trying
beating this game is no easy feat a copy
of scp-1315 has been in Foundation
containment since 1986 but in all that
time only one d-class personnel has
managed to make it to level 33. it is
not known how many levels there are but
there is theoretically a final boss the
reason why no one has been able to beat
it thus far is that with each level the
difficulty of the game increases
relatively minor challenges in the first
few levels give way to extremely
difficult life-threatening scenarios as
the player progresses these levels
broadly follow the same pattern each
time but individual levels often contain
an element of Randomness for example
level 1 that Sally and John played
contained rats but other tests have
shown subjects being swarmed by insects
and spiders often coinciding with
established phobias that the subject has
reported prior to the experiment two
hours later John and Sally were running
low on ammo with both couches pushed
against the door to the lounge they both
hunkered down behind the TV loading the
remains of their shelves into the
shotguns from out in the hallway they
could hear the heavy footsteps of more
animals rushing towards them when the
pounding on their door had first started
they assumed it had been their neighbor
coming up to complain about their
screaming and running around in the
previous levels Jon had been so deep in
thought trying to work out what their
cover story could be that when he opened
the door and saw an adult grizzly bear
standing on its hind legs in front of
him it had taken him almost too long to
react sprinting back into the lounge he
found his wife already loading Browns
into the shotgun that had suddenly
appeared on the floor in front of her
with a grim expression on her face she
seemed to have accepted their new
reality that this was a game they were
going to have to fight their way through
but with every bear they shot as it
tried to push its way into their Lounge
two more had appeared just minutes later
while they had been conservative with
their ammo aiming for the heads and not
taking any risks the pair was starting
to run dangerously low was there an
objective they were missing were they
supposed to have done something to
progress through the level Sally mashed
a couple buttons on the NES controller
and then some text appeared on the red
screen objective survive four Bears
appeared in the doorway and pushed hard
against the couch it slid out of the way
and they charged into the room Sally and
John desperately took down the first two
of them but the dreaded click of the
triggers told them they had nothing left
closing their eyes embracing themselves
for the worst the pounding of heavy paws
on their vinyl floor suddenly stopped
the Bears had disappeared level 3
complete
but whatever's next can't be worse than
that surely but it was they managed to
hold out in their apartment until Level
Nine but then the windows behind their
heads smashed into a thousand shards as
a black booted SWAT team swung into the
room with barely any time to react Sally
and John pushed their way out of the
apartment embraced themselves down to
their car slamming both doors closed
they took off racing towards the highway
as the SWAT vehicles pursued them three
hours later the couple was running low
on gas swerving their way along the
interstate their eyes on the mirrors
constantly the pair was pretty certain
they'd managed to lose their assailants
slowing their car to the speed limit
they gently weave their way through the
traffic towards the nearest gas station
trying their best not to look suspicious
the two of them went inside Keen to
stock up on supplies who knew how long
this game would go on for they had
already been active for hours and were
exhausted with the SWAT team hopefully
long behind them now the adrenaline Rush
was starting to wear off and the reality
of this situation was starting to set in
hopefully there were just 10 levels and
they only had one to go with the sinking
feeling in their chests each one of them
realized it was more than likely to be
100 definitely time to stock up on some
supplies they were barely Halfway Around
the gas station when the words level 9
complete flashed in the sky above them
both Jon and Sally froze where they were
and stared at each other over the aisles
a blue flash started past them outside
the windows then again going the other
way Sally ran over to the counter and
banged on the glass locked the door
locked the door but the teenager just
looked at her in confusion and now it
was Sally's turn to look around and see
her husband staring in horror on the
other side of the glass standing between
two gas pumps was
Sonic.exe with haunting red eyes Rose
and rows of sharp teeth and blood
dripping from his mouth
hedgehogs stared intently Sally pointed
out the window and turned to the
teenager yelling but the girl took a
step back looking scared of her the girl
couldn't see it she couldn't see Sonic
for all these challenges all the things
they'd been fighting was it just in her
head but there was no time to worry
about that Sally ran towards the door to
the back of the shop hearing the
footsteps of her husband running after
her she kicked open the fire exit but
froze immediately
Sonic.exe was standing there in front of
her smiling it was toying with them they
needed to run to get out of here as
quickly as possible but how could they
outrun Sonic hey Sonic Jon yelled from
behind her you hungry he pushed Sally
out of the way and threw a handful of
chili dogs out into the forest hearing
hungry Sonic spun around and chased
after his favorite food as quickly as
possible that had only bought them a few
moments of time but maybe that was all
that they would get Sally and John ran
back through the convene in store and
out the front they couldn't run but they
could at least try to hide a semi truck
had a slam on the brakes as the pair of
them ran across the interstate without a
choice of running anywhere else all they
could do was Dart into the woods on the
other side and hope that Sonic had a bad
sense of smell but as they ran through
the woods they could hear an ominous
voice echoing behind them gotta go fast
gotta go faster than that Sally found a
tree and dived into cover just at the
right moment her husband wasn't so lucky
there was a flash of blue and a horrible
crunching sound before his body hit the
ground
Sonic.exe was on top of him in a
heartbeat Rose of sharp teeth gnashing
Sally clasped both hands over her face
trying desperately to block out the
smell and trap her nervous breathing she
couldn't bring herself to look every
bone in her body wanted to take off
running through the forest out onto the
road to try and find some help but there
was nothing she could do she can never
outrun that thing it was too fast too
Savage even if she could convince
someone on the highway to pull over and
help her they would just tell her she
was going crazy maybe she was then the
smell of her husband's body drifted over
to her on the Wind as the crunching
sound of inhuman Jaws filled her ears
new tears flowed then silence she
couldn't hear anything not even a
whisper in the trees had she done it had
she survived then a red sneaker stepped
out from behind the tree and Sally
stared into the eyes of the blood
splattered deranged Hedgehog Sally
blinked and it was gone level 10
complete the open Forest stretched down
in front of her without a moment to
catch her breath Sally took off running
into the country on her own whatever was
coming next she had to be ready for it
now go check out scp-1594 Miss Jay's
Wizkid Schoolhouse and scp-978 desire
camera from more